The joe rogan experience.
I try not to complain about just because it's part of that is part of the job.
And I'd rather do it then work construction any day.
But sometimes mentally is tough to do a morning interview.
But if I have,
if I have,
you know,
take Adderall before dinner,
I'm snappy,
I got jumped,
I got anecdotes and then I can kind of,
I know sometimes now I've learned how to,
you got to take an interview over sometimes or they want to not go on a rant but
you have to not let them,
you know,
just cause they can get into that cutting off your jokes and eh,
funny man handlebars just cut you off.
So just learning how to,
how to do that and just having the energy and focus to be able to is it's real
helpful.
Yeah.
The morning radio thing,
if like they're good,
it's great.
It's real fun.
It's really fun.
Pro is supported and set you up.
And then sometimes they just say,
so what's funny in the world right now
in an interview the other day,
the guy asked me that exact question,
what's making you laugh right now?
Ah,
to Hannah,
but what are you talking about on stage?
Oh man,
that's another one they do.
Yeah.
Somebody asked me that before.
A show I was doing in New York.
What are you going to talk about?
Man,
just came over like,
so what are we talking about today?
Like you now,
you
dudes that would go,
well,
here's my new piece.
It's all about how man is constricted by a first his mom and then his wife and a
then ultimately his lawyer.
Yeah.
I mean,
I guess the thing is just,
I try to remember that people aren't coming from a shitty place normally.
They just don't know how to communicate to me in a way that won't make me feel
cynical and hate them.
You know what I mean?
So I gotta keep that in mind,
but in the moment it's like what the fuck it,
you just ask me what's funny in a world right now
for someone who's not a comic,
they wouldn't understand how awkward that would be.
Like when you like when you can go on a radio show and they just let you talk.
Right.
Hang out,
let's just hang out,
hang out,
talk about stuff back and forth from each other.
Yeah.
It's not a lot of them.
They can do that though.
That's the problem.
Do you ever do those radio tours?
We have to call like 10 different people and then you realize like eight of them
have the same voice,
like almost exactly.
What does this,
the radio voice,
I don't know what,
when it was tested,
when it was,
it was,
it was a,
it was a study that people,
that people like to listen to.
This right here,
we live here in Nashville.
We got Hannibal bears in the studio when alive here in Cincinnati.
We got had,
it's a couple versions of that.
This is a couple of versions of that wisdom,
you know?
And it was the sports guy as well.
Gus Johnson here for showtime.
There's the news guy.
It's just the same as um,
rappers though too.
They rappers rap voice.
You'd talk to rapidly.
My sound like me,
but then when in there wrapped it like,
you know what it is?
It's a persona.
It's just a persona that you know,
works for that situation.
I like it though.
I like the,
the Gus Johnson
type voice,
like of a guys.
Uh,
like when I say that about Gus Johnson,
I'm not putting them down.
Like,
I liked that professional.
Here we are Madison Square Garden.
I don't want a guy who's like,
Hey,
I'm like me.
Like I,
when I do the UFC,
there's a reason why I'm the color guy and I'm not the play by play guy.
I don't do the big,
here we are Joe FC one 52.
Like those guys are important.
I like that.
I mean it is as tree,
its pageantry isn't a reason why Michael buffer works well.
Yeah.
That's even more so because he's a announcer.
Let's get ready to rumble.
This pageantry dog.
It's pageants.
Yeah.
I'm not putting it down,
but it is weird radios when radio he'll cause you don't have to talk like radio
is different cause it's supposed to be your personality.
You know what I mean?
Like sports doesn't spoil as a guide.
The news is the news,
but radios was to be your vibe.
But then you sound like the dude in Saint Louis also.
You sound like the dude who was all over the place.
Every guy you know another place where that exists was that Strip club Djs?
Uh,
yeah.
I've been trying to analyze this for many years and I think with Strip club Djs,
it's like no one wants to hear a dude talking while girls are dancing naked.
You do not want to hear that guy.
So he's got to make it like a song.
Like all right,
come in to this stage.
It's amber.
Remember everybody $40 comic cons.
It's like there's an entertainment aspect to the what he's doing.
It's like he's almost like he's singing a song.
But have you been to a black strip club in Atlanta though?
No stitches.
No.
Those djs out of most amazing Dj's.
Vocally f really because they drive the tipping.
You know what I mean?
Right,
right.
They crack jokes.
I asked when I was,
it's just so funny.
It's like,
man,
you need to pay the pussy like they here.
Y'all ain't spending money.
They'll drop the track.
They come cut the track by God.
Spend some mother fucking money.
Look what she's doing up there.
She's up there.
The Atlanta Dj's and Strip club.
Amazing.
They to Atlanta,
probably just other black.
That black strip clubs like the DJ drives that Shit and is the driving force and
as an entertainer in addition to add,
he adds to it.
See now I'm weighing the potential dangers of going to a black strip club in
Atlanta with the entertainment aspect of how amazing.
It must be dangerous man.
Isn't that a guy like me?
I'm sure.
I'm sure I need to go.
If I go with you,
I'll go with you.
I could slide right in.
I'm not even that blood.
Then I play but not black in a black strip club.
The djs,
the right famous ones is fate.
I don't know the names though cause I have a bit,
but you go to somewhere uh,
magic city or magic city.
A few other ones in Atlanta.
Uh,
the Dj is is,
is important and makes the Strip was more money and a strep was probably end up
tipping out the DJ.
Sure.
Yeah.
They have like an arrangement,
right?
Yeah.
My friend Eddie used to work at a strip club.
I used to go and visit him at work watching who's a DJ.
So I got to,
I got to see the craft.
I got to see how everybody does it.
It's interesting the relationship they all have,
it becomes just like,
I mean you might as well be working in a restaurant.
Everybody develops the same sort of blue lights man.
Exactly.
People get naked and that's,
it's weird cause it's porn.
Porn is like that too.
Like those people get used to each other and it becomes just like any other
normal,
see you later.
Good.
Jason on I'm
season.
I think it's probably funny when it's just somebody you fucked like two years
ago.
Oh good to see you again.
They,
I think they have definitely a more relaxed attitude about it.
Yeah.
You know,
if you run into somebody that used to fuck out of nowhere,
you're like,
Hey,
this is me getting me.
I'll see you naked naked.
All right.
You take care of.
Don't mind that Mo.
It's weird when you haven't seen someone at 20 years and then you get to see
like,
whoa,
this is weird.
This is weird.
Hello,
Nina Hartley.
I met her.
She's a very nice lady.
She was doing Kevin Pereira as podcasts.
Yeah.
I Sat,
sat in with her and talked to her for awhile.
She does everything with gloves on,
man.
Really?
Yeah.
She was like sex sessions with people.
She puts like surgical gloves on one.
Yes,
he does corporates,
right.
Does she?
I think a lot,
Phil.
Yeah.
A lot of them to do like corporate gigs.
Corporates in quotes.
The quotes,
I guess.
Sort of.
Yeah,
and the way that corporates,
private privates.
Yes.
She probably does a lot of privates.
Yeah.
Like you know.
Very few comics do privates.
What would you do if someone said,
hey man,
Hannibal Burress,
I want you to come over and just do comedy.
Just for me.
I'm just a big comedy fan but I don't like going to comedy clubs because it's
fucking,
I don't like laughing around are the people so we can just do your act for me
and I'll pay you what you get paid for like a regular show for a packed house
for no,
they add the charge to my,
my corporate college.
Right.
Okay.
Well I wouldn't want to do that.
So can I bring somebody with me?
Well now you're worried about your safety.
Don't worry.
The guys only going to masturbate.
He promised this nothing really crazy.
He just wants to watch you just,
he's gonna keep his pants.
Well you keep a towel on.
Nah,
I'm not doing that good cause I don't need the money that bad cause I got my own
supplement business
so I'm that,
you know,
I could do stuff as I want to do it,
you know.
All right.
How about if the dude wears like a space suit?
The space suit?
Yeah.
She sits there with a space.
You don't know my logo set.
Fucking full set.
How line?
Say
for one dude,
but one dude,
can I bring an opener?
No,
to warm up.
He's going to watch your past specials so I can't even,
I can't even drop him stuff.
I got to do an hour news.
Well,
it feels a fan man.
You already know.
He already said it.
Yeah.
You mentioned you paid due to do a one on one showed it does bits.
You already know fucker.
This shit from your last call.
Crowd work.
So this is crazy.
Look at this place.
50 gs.
That's my rate for that weird ass shit.
Okay.